hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the brand new apple watch
series 8. i am so excited about this
because i have been using the apple
watch since the first version and i
strongly believe that because i have
been wearing an apple watch and i know
what is normal for my body that this has
actually helped save my life this year
so if you guys haven't seen that video i
did post it on my channel but long story
short i got a blood clot in my shoulder
and then i ended up getting a pulmonary
embolism which that clot then traveled
to my lungs which could be incredibly
dangerous if you're not familiar with
blood clots i'm actually the world
thrombosis patient advocate this year
and i'm so excited to be able to help
spread this information and hopefully
save lives because i am active i'm
healthy i'm well i'm not the youngest
that i've ever been but for me it was
kind of crazy because i never thought
that something like this could ever
affect me and when it did i realized how
common it is if i could help bring this
information to someone it could
potentially save your life so come join
me as we test this out but first we have
to unbox it rewind
today we have the brand new apple
watches in the studio we have the new
apple watch series 8 and the new apple
watch se let's unbox we're going to open
up the aluminum starlight series 8 first
now these are both starlight so they're
going to look very similar but they're
not
the apple watch unboxing it's so
exciting i love their packaging i love
the design it's such a fun opening
oh
surprise
oh boy here you are my little apple
watch i'm so excited because last year
during my apple watch review i had an
injury oh no
i'm not even a mile in and
sometimes hills bother my knee and i
almost gave out running down this hill
but i'm really excited this year because
i feel like i'm all healed up so i'll
hopefully be able to get you guys some
good content as far as fitness is
concerned so this is the 45 millimeter
apple watch series 8.
my old apple watch is the 41 millimeter
which i did pre-order the gold 41
millimeters i basically just did a
simple upgrade that's pretty much gonna
look exactly the same but this is the 45
millimeter starlight version i love the
starlight it's so
pretty i'm just gonna set my other apple
watch aside i'm sorry
you've been replaced no hard feelings
though what do we have in here
we've got our
apple watch charger so i don't really
ever use these ones anymore but this is
kind of cool because now you'll be able
to charge the new airpods pro 2 case
with an apple watch charger okay here is
our sport band we also have some apple
watch bands as well to check out
these colors look so good together
oh look at that
beautiful so here's the size difference
between the
45 and the 41. okay let's set this up
really quick and then we're going to
unbox the se
so while that's setting up let's check
out some of our apple watch bands this
is the sequoia pure platinum nike sport
loop this is the elderberry sport loop
and this one is the midnight sport loop
oh are you done it's done oh my goodness
look at you look at you
oh you're so
beautiful
oh wow it's been a while since i've had
the larger watch face oh my sister's
texting me so the main difference with
the series 8 as opposed to the series 7
is it now has a temperature sensor and
for me i'm very excited about this
because temperature sensing is such a
huge part of ovulation and cycle
tracking so for everyone with a period
this is going to be really cool now the
thing that was also kind of interesting
is the only way that it will be able to
do the temperature sensing is if you do
wear your apple watch to sleep now i
definitely am not a huge fan of wearing
watches to sleep and i do have the aura
ring which i have been wearing for over
a year almost a year and a half at this
point and this also does temperature
sensing and it does your heart rate it
attracts all sorts of different types of
things with sleep so i really love
wearing the ring as opposed to the watch
but i am definitely going to try this
out and it'll be really cool to kind of
compare the two and see how they
differentiate now what's interesting
about the apple watch series 8 as
opposed to the aura ring is this has two
temperature sensors there's one that's
actually on your skin and then there's
another that's inside of the glass so
with that it's able to get the
temperature of the outside surrounding
area as well as the temperature on your
wrist so using ai in various different
types of algorithms it's able to
determine a way more precise body
temperature because it's able to see
what the outside temperature is and your
body temperature and then kind of
configure that to get you the most
accurate details and it is going to take
five nights of sleep to be able to start
that prediction and get that in motion
so unfortunately in this review it may
not be a full five days so i might not
be able to demo that feature but i
definitely will do a follow-up either on
social or a whole separate video and
show you how that's working now when i
do sleep with my apple watch i like
using one of these soft bands because
they're so much more comfortable so now
let's unbox some of these apple watch
bands so this is the 45 millimeter
midnight sport loop so we're gonna open
this one up and this is gonna be the one
that i'm probably going to be putting on
to wear
look at that
very nice although this looks so pretty
these sport loop ones are so much more
comfortable
oh yeah this looks great this 45
millimeter is actually nice because this
is gonna be a great transition into the
49 millimeter apple watch ultra can't
wait to get my hands on that one okay
let's check out these other two bands
and then we'll open up the apple watch
se
oh this one's really pretty i like the
elderberry a lot
this one's so nice too
so this is the 40 millimeter apple watch
essie
look at this one oh i love it
it's like a little baby such a size
difference
definitely for my wrist i do prefer the
smaller apple watches but looking at the
45 millimeter it really does look so
good i'm so used to seeing the smaller
one so i can see so much more of this
watch face the one thing that i like
though about the new sc is look what
they did they color matched the back of
the watch face to match the apple watch
that you've chosen so this is the
starlight and it has a beautiful light
starlight back so here's the size
comparison this is the starlight 40
millimeter se and this is the starlight
45 millimeter series 8. you can also see
the differences in the sensors because
obviously this does have your
temperature your blood oxygen your ecg
and this of course does not have it so
you can see the differences in the backs
of the sensors so those
are a completely different sensor look i
do like how the sc color matched the
edge of the apple watch with the back
now so that looks really nice so now
everything is all set up i'm going to
put this on and start testing
so you might notice that i am wearing
two apple watches this is my series
seven and this is my series eight i do
have this hooked up to a demo account
because i didn't wanna get any
conflicting data and mix it in with my
new account until i actually get my own
personal watch so this is my review
device now if you guys aren't familiar
with the apple watch it's pretty
powerful it can take your blood oxygen
levels it can track your heart rate it
can take an ecg and now on the series 8
it has temperature sensing this is so
useful for anyone who has a period this
will help us not only track our cycle
but it will also help you predict
ovulation and this is critical if you're
trying to get pregnant or trying to not
get pregnant thank you apple watch so
one of the big differences with this new
apple watch in comparison to the aura
ring is this actually has two
temperature sensors so there's one
that's actually inside of a glass and
then there's another that is close to
your skin so not only is it reading the
temperature of your skin it's also
getting the outside temperature of your
surroundings so that'll be able to give
you a more accurate prediction of what
your actual skin temperature is now
because i've been tracking my workouts
for so long i'm able to go back in time
and see my progress unfortunately since
i had that little health scare this year
my progress has declined but i'm able to
go back over a year ago see where i was
and work my way back up and to help with
that apple fitness has been such a game
changer with your apple watch when you
get one brand new you get three months
free to test it out and there's so many
different classes there's yoga there's
hit classes there's bugs all over here
there's dance classes there's running
there's so many different activities
that apple has provided these super high
quality classes to help you get in the
best shape ever i actually got a chance
to visit the apple fitness plus studios
in los angeles and it's so cool the way
that fitness plus integrates with the
apple watch is so incredible because
you're able to do these classes the
apple watch connects to the class and as
the trainers are interacting and saying
things like check your heart rate those
will flash up on the screen and you'll
be able to see that not only on your
device but also on your apple watch this
works on your iphone your ipad they even
have an apple tv app so pretty much
wherever you go you'll have access to
fitness classes oh i'm going to start my
yoga class now okay here we go
[Music]
oh
this is my demo watch i just got an
award for my first yoga workout it's
also cool because when you do the
classes it'll give you a little update
that says you did yoga with jessica
[Music]
so now not only are we testing out the
apple watch but this is also a little
demo of action mode on the new iphone
14. now i'm excited about some of the
new features that they've added for
runners you can do this really cool
thing called dynamic pacing which to me
kind of feels like when you're racing
your shadow in mario kart so even if i'm
running the same route every single day
i'll be able to see if i'm getting any
better so in os9 this update is actually
available to all apple watches dating
back to series 4. this will give runners
access to their vertical oscillation
their ground contact time and their
stride length so this is going to be
really awesome for people to be able to
see how they're improving and things
that they may need to do
to actually become a better runner
[Music]
something else i'm excited about is
you're going to be able to have heart
rate zones that are generated
automatically based on your past
performance this is going to be so great
for being able to track how well you're
doing or what you might need to do to
step it up the heart rate never lies
[Music]
the apple watch plus apple tv and apple
fitness plus is such an incredible
combination behind me i have an entire
fitness studio right here on my tv and
i'm using my iphone as the apple tv
remote and i'm going to be connecting
this to my old apple watch it'll look
exactly the same on the series 8. i'm
only demoing this here because i already
have it connected and since this is my
review unit i don't have this connected
to my tv right now so i think this class
is good we're going to do this hit with
jamie rae it's a 10 minute pure dance
get ready to see some moves so we're
going to select this and it's so great
because this automatically will connect
to my apple watch it starts not only on
the watch but also on your tv
yes yes i'm in here
and you can see up here
oh my apple watch data
and here's my rings
[Music]
i just built my exercise goal
exercise ring has been closed
and here's the after workout summary
it's cool because not only do they show
you this here on your apple tv you can
get all of the important data but of
course this will sync directly to your
apple fitness app and this goes directly
to your health kit data i also love when
you finish a workout if you have friends
that you're sharing your activity data
with they'll actually get a little
summary of your workout and they'll show
you which workout you took so if they
want to take the same they can just
click into it directly from their apple
watch and they can take the same class
even though there are bike classes on
the apple fitness plus it's really cool
because a lot of gym equipment will
actually connect with your apple watch
so peloton for example allows you to
connect to your apple watch and you'll
be able to have all of your heart rate
data show up on the device matt wilpers
let's get it
so let me show you guys how this works
just hold your apple watch up here
it asks to connect i click ok i'm so
stoked that you're here
the pedals movement all right also the
resistance from around 20. i'll put a
link in the description
this little bike adapter all right
silky resistance
we're gonna go one minute
[Music]
there's so many different workouts that
you can do on your apple watch and when
you click into the workout section
you can just choose the workout that
you're doing i'm going to be doing an
indoor run here we go
what is up built up alberts here it's
time for a five minute warmup run so
since i do have a peloton tread i do
like taking these classes but it's
really cool because if i decide that i
want to take one of the apple fitness
plus classes i can just put this on
manual and i can take the classes on my
phone in apple fitness plus so even if
you don't have a tread that has classes
you can do running classes on apple
fitness plus
[Music]
so the apple watch se is really
interesting especially from a price
point because the starting price for gps
is 249 and with cellular it's 299. now i
feel like that is still a pretty high
price point but if this is something
that you want to get for your child this
is the best way to go because you'll be
able to set up the family account so
they don't have to have an iphone or
even if you have a friend or somebody
who might want to have an apple watch
but they don't have an iphone you're
able to set this up in the family
account it's really cool because they
have a lot of parameters that you can
set if it is for a child you can set
school time so you can have access to
certain apps or you can block access to
certain apps so that if they are
supposed to be doing schoolwork or
they're in school they won't be able to
get distracted now of course the sc
because of the cost cut you are going to
be cutting some of the features you
won't have the blood oxygen sensing you
won't have the ecg and you won't have
the new temperature sensing in the
series 8 but you'll still have all of
the core features plus it does have the
crash detect which i think is one of the
most important safety features that
apple has implemented into all of their
devices this year
[Music]
so the only time that your temperature
is being recorded is when you sleep and
that's because when you're out about
during the day you're running around
you're doing different activities so you
don't really have a constant temperature
and when you sleep that's when your body
temperature is regulated and you're able
to get a really good read you will have
to sleep with this for at least five
nights to get your baseline body
temperature and i would recommend that
if you don't actually plan on ever using
these temperature features and you do
have the apple watch series seven i
don't really think there's a huge need
to upgrade because the apple watch
series seven is still an incredible
apple watch but if you do plan on
sleeping with this and you do want these
new features like the longer battery
life with the new temperature sensor
then maybe it is worth an upgrade for
you so the main new feature in the
series 8 is the temperature sensor and
cycle tracking so i'm going to set this
up now and i have it here on my home
screen and when i click this it tells
you to open up the health app and set up
your cycle tracking oh boy when was my
last period hold on
let me look is this going to be too much
information for the internet do they
need do you guys need to know this you
probably don't need to know this but
we're gonna great now everyone knows
what my last period was
oh
great this is also reminding you to set
up your sleep schedule now this isn't
new to the series eights this has
something that you have been able to do
in the past few apple watches is take
your ecg it's pretty amazing that you're
able to do this complex task on your
wrist so here's the sinus rhythm that's
normal and here are some of the
abnormalities like the afib
low or high heart rate inconclusive this
is also kind of interesting because it
does tell you that it cannot detect a
heart attack and you know what also it
can't detect
blood clots or a stroke now that's where
it's kind of interesting because i did
have a blood clot and my apple watch did
not alert me of it but the things that
it did alert me was my heart rate was
elevated and because my heart rate was
elevated when i was not doing anything
that for me was abnormal and that was
one of the signs that i kind of realized
like something is not right so while it
may not be able to alert you of what's
wrong those little triggers can
definitely signify something is wrong
and you should seek help so let's uh
let's take our ecg shall we
[Music]
sinus rhythm this ecg does not show any
signs of
afib i actually got a little worried i
was like what if i'm filming this and
then i find out something's not right
that would literally be just my luck now
this also pops up on the health app so
you get a notification and you can
cruise in and see your full report and
what's great about this is you can then
take this and send it to your doctor or
send it to a friend if you just want to
be like hey look at my heart it's cool
dude i don't know whatever you want to
do with it make it an nft that's up to
you so while i was in the hospital i was
constantly being monitored for my blood
oxygen level but when i went home
obviously i don't have a machine there
to do that 24 7 except yes you do you
have the apple watch which can also test
for blood oxygen levels so it will alert
you if you have a low blood oxygen level
and you can test your blood oxygen level
any time
cool 99
i keep getting so worried every time i
take a test i'm like something bad can
happen we good fam
we good there are some new apple watch
faces for the series eight but this is
my favorite one and this is what i go
back to because it has all of my data
and everything that i need i've got my
workouts i can get to my messages my
cycle and this is my heart rate data so
if i click on that i can see what my
current heart rate is i can see my
resting heart rate my walking average
and all the workouts that i have done
and up here i have my rings i like to
have easy access to those to see if i
need to do any more activities for the
day or if i'm good to go i also like
that i can change the colors of this too
you fancy now the number one thing that
i use my apple watch for yes it's great
for tracking health and your fitness uh
but i use it to find my iphone more
times than i would ever like to admit at
least five times a day when you swipe up
you'll get this little notification
panel so you can hit
[Music]
found it i walk around my house
like this
all day long
so this does have an upgraded battery so
you'll get about 18 hours of battery
life now if you turn on low power mode
that can get you up to 36 hours you'll
still be able to use all of the core
features but a lot of the background
things like the blood oxygen sensing and
the heart rate detection that will be
turned off until you go back out of low
power mode also crash detection is
something new in the series 8 and in all
of the iphone 14s so they have now made
it so that if you happen to get yourself
into a car crash and you're unresponsive
the apple watch and the iphone will
automatically call the emergency
response team and they'll hopefully be
able to get to you i will not be testing
out and hopefully we'll never have to
use this isn't new to just series 8 but
watch os 9 is bringing a lot of new
features to not only the new apple watch
but also the older generations dating
back to the series 4. they now have the
capability to be able to do multiple
workout activities so for things like
triathlons you'll be able to switch from
running to cycling to swimming without
having to start an entirely new workout
and also they now have true sleep
tracking so you'll be able to track your
rem sleep and it gives you some updated
graphs now i personally don't sleep with
my apple watch so i'm really excited to
kind of test this out a little bit
further i have tested it out in the past
on my last review i did sleep with it
last night for the first time and it was
really comfortable because this is the
sport loop and it's soft and i didn't
even feel like i had something on my
wrist which was actually pretty exciting
i hate to keep talking about this crazy
health scare that i had but it literally
changed my life and i never had to take
daily medication before
and trying to remember if you took a
medication or not i think was like one
of the most difficult things and you
think that you would remember taking the
pill could not for the life of me ever
remember so one of the new updates they
have in macho s9 is medication tracking
so you can put in the medication that
you're on and it will not only remind
you when you have to take it but it will
also alert you of any drug interaction
so if you're taking multiple medications
and one of those may interfere with each
other it will alert you and say hey hold
on a second contact your doctor don't
mix these medications and i think that's
so incredible and i never ever in a
million years would have ever thought
that that would have been something that
i needed and hopefully i won't ever have
to use it again but i feel like you know
i'm nearing the retirement home at this
point so i might be using it way more
often than i might like there's so many
of the things that i love about the
apple watch another is the apple fitness
plus workouts that they have they have
audio workouts where you can go outside
and do time to walk or time to run and
it's really fun because you don't have
to be inside just doing workouts on your
tv or on your iphone or on your ipad you
can actually go out and enjoy and listen
to some really great audio prompts that
they have time to walk is actually
really fun because they have a bunch of
celebrities and well-known people and
they do little interviews with them
where these people take you for walks
and listen to some of their favorite
music another thing that i like is they
have the mindfulness app so if i need
just a few minutes of some mindful
meditation i have that right here on my
wrist which i'm actually gonna do right
now because it's almost time for bed so
let's do a nice little mindful
meditation to lead us out of this video
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed this and if you have
any questions about the apple watch
please leave them in the comments below
and be sure to check out all the other
videos that i have that are apple
related like the iphone apple watch
ultra they will be somewhere here in
this end card i look forward to seeing
you guys in my next video don't forget
to subscribe
hit the bell to be notified when i post
a new video and i'll see you in the next
one